[Music]
now to a special report from the 8 news
now it my husband enters a local
hospital for a medical procedure so why
did his wife die just outside Vanessa
Murphy has been looking into this tragic
death and how changes have been made so
this never happens again
[Music]
that was also one of the things that
attracted me to her her voice David Litt
recalls a classmate named Lear singing
at a talent show back in the early 60s
so I called her and we started dating
from there they became High School
sweethearts once you meet her you you
wouldn't forget her marriage and his
enlistment in the military followed been
a tour in Vietnam and today as a veteran
David receives Medical Care at the VA in
August of 2020 he went in for a
transfusion he says Lear didn't drive
much due to health issues but she wanted
to go with her husband so she dropped
him off parked the car and tried to head
inside but she was turned away they
allowed her to come in to tell me that
she couldn't come in
and that's when I gave her my phone
said okay I'll call you you know find
out
how you're doing there was a no visitor
policy at the emergency department at
the time due to the pandemic I think
that could have been handled a lot
differently Lear was 75 years old the
temperature on record for that day as
high as 110. still Lear went to wait in
the car in the parking lot that was
around 9 30 around noon a doctor on
their way in saw her in the car which
wasn't running with the windows rolled
down she said she didn't have much gas
so she couldn't let the car run but to
David that doesn't sound quite right one
thing I
made a habit of Never Getting below half
a tank of gas then around 2 30 after
David tried calling Lear and there was
no answer he asked Hospital staff to
check on her shortly after he heard an
announcement rapid response in the
parking lot Lear was found unresponsive
in the car her body temperature
109. so I'm doing compressions
and I I I'm across the hall from whether
it's taking place but I knew it was her
without even seeing I knew it was her
Lear was pronounced dead inside the
hospital her cause of death hyperthermia
the unfortunate reality was we had spent
so much time on risk assessing protect
veterans protect staff and after that
incident occurred we had to take a step
back and say well there's a secondary
risk too because of the weather out here
William Karen is the head of va Southern
Nevada Health Care System a policy is a
policy but with the heat and this was an
elderly woman with a limb with her own
health issues she wasn't a veteran but
do you think a mistake was made at the
people who interacted with her at the
door yeah I think we could go back in
time hindsight and review every single
detail but to say that someone was was
malicious or Reckless I wouldn't say
that in the least that the the goal was
the greater good of protecting all
veterans multiple departments at the VA
investigated the incident the i-team's
request for the results of the
investigations were denied while we've
appealed we also asked Karen about this
but any of those results of the
investigation typically that's not
something that we would share
outright were you aware that there was
further investigation no
first time that
I'm hearing this
his policy was changed the day Lear died
to allow one visitor to accompany a
patient and to increase Patrols in the
parking lot were you aware that they
changed policy after that
no it'll help someone else if it gets
the same situation arises but it's not
helping me at all David says for now
he's trying to get used to life without
his wife of 57 years by his side I know
it's going to take time Vanessa Murphy
live local now